- Studying the past,
seeing what worked before,
because then you can be better
prepared for the present
and you can get wealthier in the future.
You can learn and you can make money
from anywhere in the world.
Learn what you love and focus on it.
Don't work for somebody else's dream.
We're all human, we all make mistakes,
we all learn.
- He's an American penny
stock trader and entrepreneur.
He's best known for earning
four million dollars
by day trading while at university.
He turned a $12,415 bar mitzvah gift
into 1.65 million dollars
by the time he was 21,
by day trading penny stocks.
He's Timothy Sykes,
and here are his top ten rules to success.
And as always guys, as
you're watching the videos,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Also as you are writing something down
it's much more likely to
stick in your head too.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- Hey, Tim Sykes, millionaire
mentor and trader here,
with my ten keys to success.
Check this place out,
we're here in Cambodia.
I know it's kind of a weird place
to do a little educational video,
but Evan Carmichael had me on his channel,
so I'm going to give his
viewers my 10 keys for success.
Number one, study the past.
We're here in Cambodia, we're
looking at it, it's beautiful,
but we're also learning from the past.
For me, I study the stock market,
my top students study the stock market.
The key to success in the stock market
is not just finding hot
picks or breaking news,
it's studying the past,
seeing what worked before,
because then you can be better
prepared for the present
and you can get wealthier in the future.
Rule number two, key for success.
Keep an open mind.
I know many of you guys would never come
to a place like Cambodia.
It's hot, I'm sweating, right,
I'm eating weird food, my stomach
wasn't feeling that great,
but I keep an open mind,
because life is all about exploring.
It's not just about financial gain,
it's about growing your brain
and your knowledge and experience.
That's what I love.
Key to success number three.
Let's see, I would say planning,
but I'm not very good at planning.
I would say just going with the flow,
and just being open to different things.
I didn't plan on making this video,
but Evan was nice enough to
make a little video about me
and I wanted to do something in return,
so I'm going with it.
I'm here in Cambodia,
tomorrow I'm actually
going to the Philippines,
but freaking love it.
I'll make a video from anywhere.
Key to success number four.
You can learn and you can make money
from anywhere in the world.
We're at a very unique
time in history right now.
You have the internet.
You're watching me, I'm not
necessarily watching you,
but I can communicate with
you, I can leave comments,
we can go back and forth, we can interact,
that wasn't possible
just a few decades ago.
This new technology has
opened up a whole new world
of education and interaction,
take advantage of it.
Don't get left out.
Don't just watch a few YouTube
videos, use everything.
Use Twitter, use Facebook, use Snapchat,
use Pinterest, use Instagram,
all the social media helps
us get more connected.
Number five, use social media,
get your name out there.
Get your wisdom out there.
If you're an expert in anything,
you can make a lot of money,
you can find a lot of success,
you don't just have to be a
doctor or a lawyer any more,
there's so much money in the world,
there's so much interest
and there's so many people
and so many interesting subjects.
All you have to do is be open minded,
that's kind of what I am.
Rule number six for success.
Don't just take the traditional route.
I know a lot of older people,
your parents, your grandparents,
think that success has to be down
like a very certain narrow hallway,
when in fact success is everything.
The world is fantastic.
I've been fortunate to visit
over a hundred plus countries,
I've met so many different people
and experienced different cultures,
we're a lot more similar
than a lot of people think that we are,
we're all humans,
we're all in this great
experience and journey together.
Number seven, I would say ...
I'm trying to keep this very general
and very open to everybody.
I would say focus on what you love.
You know, I love to travel, I love to eat,
I love to trade stocks, I love to teach,
I love to get my message out there now
through social media.
And just learn what you
love and focus on it.
Don't work for somebody else's dream,
because no matter how
much money you're making
or how successful you are,
you're not focusing on yourself,
and you have to be a little
selfish in this life,
you have to do what you love
and figure out what you love.
Number eight, study, study, study,
so that you really
understand yourself better.
Study a whole multitude
of different subjects
and see, wait a minute,
what are you interested in?
What's going to really
pique your interest?
I was a philosophy major in college,
all my friends were business and finance,
but I took a philosophy
class and I was like,
wow, I like thinking outside the box,
I like how this, you know, makes me feel,
I'm not a very good philosopher,
I was actually the worst one in the class,
because I didn't smoke weed and
I actually care about money,
but at least I learned and now
because of my philosophical teachings
I kind of have a little bit
of a different education
that I bring to the stock market
and now the teaching world,
and frankly, that's why
I have so much success.
Number nine, focus on
your long term goals.
I know we live in a world
full of instant gratification
and you want money now, you want fame now,
you want success now, but
if you want true success,
it's going to take not just
days, weeks, or months,
I'm not talking about going viral
and being some viral sensation
or being like some kid star
or if you have like an
amazing voice or something,
I'm talking about great, lasting success
over the course of your
life, it's a journey,
and it's going to take
years if not decades,
and you're going to have ups
and you're going to have downs,
and you have to respect
your entire journey.
It's not just about where you end up,
it's not just about the success
that you achieve at the end,
it's the whole experience.
That's life, that's the beauty of this.
And number ten, do not be
afraid of making mistakes.
Do not be afraid of failure,
or if you're a stock
trader like me, loss, okay.
Some of my biggest losses
have helped mold me
and they helped develop
me into a better trader,
into a better teacher.
Obviously they suck, but again,
we're all human, we all
make mistakes, we all learn.
And lessons that we learn from
our losses and our mistakes
and that we take into the future,
that helps us make us better.
So don't just ignore these lessons,
don't just try to pretend
that you're perfect,
don't sweep losses under the rug.
Rule number one for me in the stock market
is cut losses quickly,
that's only because I've
taken several big losses
in my career and I never
want that feeling again.
So now it's made me a
more conservative trader,
and teacher,
and I was very angry with
those losses at first,
now I'm very grateful for them.
I appreciate the entire journey,
and I want you to also.
These are my ten keys to success.
I'm going to go continue
exploring more of Cambodia
and Angkor Wat and Angkor Thom and Bayon
and all these amazing places.
The world is a beautiful place,
you're capable of anything,
ignore the negativity, embrace positivity
let's live!
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
Chris asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know,
what did Timothy say
that had the biggest
impact on you and why?
What are you going to take from this
and immediately apply to
your life or your business?
Leave it in the comments below,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Rhonda Young,
Rhonda, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
and for entering in the book
contest that we had last month.
I really really really
appreciate your support.
(upbeat music)
- So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- Yeah, I'm not professional
at all, I'm just real.
This is an important lesson, be real.
Be honest, don't be
afraid of making mistakes,
don't be afraid of
showing who you truly are,
I know there's a lot of people that think,
oh you have to wear like a
fancy tie and suit all the time
and you can't make mistakes
and you have to be so
prepared for everything,
that's not realistic, okay.
The more real you are,
the better you'll do
in whatever field you are.
We're all human, okay?
Skynet doesn't take over the
world for another few decades.
So for right now, we're all that's here.
We're the kings and queens of this world.
So just act human, and
you might be surprised
at how people react to you.
- You start to look, what
can I do to get happy?
It's not just about money,
it's about self sufficiency,
and finding yourself.
And for me it's not, you know,
I took 12,000, I'm now at 4.5
million in trading profits,
that's cool, but the journey along the way
helped me find myself and build myself.
And I chose not to work on Wall Street
but to travel all over the world
because I love that personally.
Try different stuff but see how it feels.
I want more people
thinking like scientists,
like testing testing testing,
refining refining refining.
But you got to break the rat race cycle,
where it's just like money
is going to solve everything.
It won't.
- Yeah, I hear you.
- Even though I teach how
to make money, that's,
you know, it's kind of contradictory.
Some people are like, well why do you--
- We want to make money
to have some flexibility
and freedom in our lives,
but it's not everything.
- Exactly, you need to
get out of, you know,
working for somebody else's dream.
So if you have a little
savings or some money,
then you're working on your own dreams.
- [Host] Right right, exactly.
- Why do you think you
were so good at investing?
- Um, at first I was
actually trying to invest
in big companies but my
portfolio wasn't really moving.
So I gravitated towards lower
price stocks, penny stocks.
And that really got my accounts moving.
They're more volatile, they're riskier,
but they're simpler.
They usually have one or
two products, you know,
so they're either going to
succeed big or fail big.
So what I try and do is ride the momentum
for a few days or a few hours
when they announce good
news, a big partnership,
or something like that,
and I make my money grow,
like you were talking about earlier,
you know, trying to make $10 or $100.
So I keep it simple and I'm always focused
on the big goal at the end,
but I'm taking small
profits along the way.
- The key to being successful
is to work harder than other people.
Because everybody wants success.
Everybody wants a Lamborghini,
everybody wants freedom.
But, what are you willing
to do to get there?
That's my question to you, you know.
We're here at the most
prestigious university
in America, Harvard, fantastic.
I'm very honored, thank
you for having me here.
The people who have gotten here
have worked their butts off to get here.
But that's just the beginning.
Whether you're in college or
you're going to go to college
or you're out of college,
this is a lifelong
journey where you have to
continually work hard, work
harder than other people,
to get ahead.
A lot of people give
up at different times.
I'm not longer at that stage, you know.
When I had my big loss,
I basically gave up.
For a year I was in the gutter.
But I came back and I said, you know what,
this was a mistake that I made investing.
It wasn't the patterns.
I didn't go against what I had learned
to make all my millions before this loss.
I invested.
And I didn't do my full due diligence.
And that was my mistake.
I eventually got back into trading,
I saw more patterns,
and I became the number one ranked trader
out of 50,000 on Covestor in 2007 to 2011.